you know there's been a lot of reports
out there i can't say i agree with all
of them uh certainly but i support this
guy you know i think that's what needs
to be said
i don't know
um what anybody's writing or what
anybody thinks but
this foot injury wasn't his fault you
know this was a total accident it was
really wasn't his fault and it's a
serious injury i know some people are
smarting at it but it's really not a
laughing matter the guy is is was hurt
he was innocent he didn't do anything
wrong and the helmet thing is a personal
matter to him you know he has a strong
feeling about
what he's worn on his head and we're
supporting them
that is john gruden the raiders head
coach who has no choice chris sims but
to support antonio brown they have
invested much in this guy and they know
that he is temperamental and that he
could get himself in a position where
he's upset with gruden upset with the
team upset with anyone who doesn't fully
and completely support this this
ridiculous effort to try to wear the
helmet that he wants to wear it's that
simple and i feel bad for john gruden
he's in a he's in a box he is he can't
say anything but i support this guy
right you know no he can't and you know
even him
even him saying it's not his fault i
mean
it is his fault that he got into a
cryotherapy machine without any footwear
on i mean unless what somebody lied to
him and he just didn't know i mean maybe
that's the case either way john gruden
is saying all the right things he is and
it's going to go over good in the locker
room too that he's sticking up for a guy
that way and not selling them down the
river and and all of those things too i
mean there's going to be certain guys
that go oh i wonder if he would stick up
for me you know number 50 on the roster
as compared to antonio no maybe not but
that's the way life is i mean stars best
at their work whatever it do usually
they get treated a little differently
than the guys that are way farther down
the line uh the other thing i'll say
mike gruden does have experience with
guys like this and i mean
not quite me but i certainly wasn't a
choir boy all the time but a lot of but
a lot of guys we had down there in tampa
bay certainly had personalities whether
it was a keyshawn johnson a warren sapp
a simeon rice there was a lot of guys
through the years and for the most part
he handled them pretty well i mean as
far as dealing with their their their
tempers or whatever else their their
personalities
what did he eventually do with keyshawn
johnson though he reached his lifetime
limit of dealing with keyshawn johnson
and sent him home
during the 2003 season get out of here
keyshawn we're gonna pay you to get the
hell out of here right so i think john
gruden will take it and take it and take
it until he no longer takes it now we're
a long way away from that but antonio
brown is planting the seeds now of
something that will cause john gruden to
eventually snap at some point down the
road he will have had enough of this and
there's mike mayok if you're watching on
nbcsn he has to be beside himself i i
tweeted on friday after this all hit the
fan mike mayhawk when does he get up and
walk out and go back to nfl network
because he did not sign up for this he
is an old school bill belichick football
guy the notion that a guy won't wear a
football helmet because it's too old and
outdated and he needs or he wants to
wear that one and won't wear a new one
has got to be the kind of thing that has
mike mayok just ready to say what did i
get myself into here and the nfl had
been very quiet about this chris nothing
on the record from the league this all
happened late friday afternoon here we
are monday morning
7 a.m brian mccarthy nfl spokesman
posted this on twitter without
identifying anyone by name
the player can't practice or play in
games with equipment that's not approved
if he doesn't play or practice he is in
breach of his contract and does not get
paid nfl policy is that helmets have to
be certified by
n-o-s-c-a-e they don't certify equipment
that's older than 10 years that in a
nutshell is the problem and you pointed
out during break we didn't even get to
this in the first segment the idea that
antonio brown at one point took his old
helmet and tried to paint it with the
raiders colors and sneak it onto the
field that's how far this has come this
is the level of zaniness that we are
dealing with here and i have no idea
chris where it's gonna go from here no
absolutely no idea and uh that pretty
you know it's good to see the nfl put
that statement out there that's gonna
quiet a lot of the noise and i think
that's what we can expect to hear from
the arbitrator about the case from
antonio brown when when the time comes i
mean there's just no ground to stand on
especially this day and age where we're
talking about player safety we're not
just going to let a player i don't give
a damn if it's antonio brown peyton
manning just do whatever he wants and
antonio brown can quit football antonio
i mean peyton manning retired and man
the nfl ratings were still amazing and
gosh peyton manning is about as big as
it ever came in
as sorry as a star in the nfl so antonio
brown if he wants to do all this crap
he's not going to win this battle and
the other thing other thing mike you
know you talked about the planning of
the seeds with john gruden right and you
know when will be that time where he can
take no more i'll tell you when it'll be
when antonio brown can't deliver for his
offense anymore that'll be the big issue
as soon as there's slippage there that's
when you'll see things really go bad but
as long as antonio brown starts to carve
people up in otas and training camp and
still has you know uh all his physical
ability he's gonna have the backing of a
guy like john gruden because john gruden
believes in him and what he can do for
his offense
meanwhile tuesday night episode two of
this year's hard knocks now last week i
think they really tiptoed no pun
intended well maybe around the foot
issue and and never explained what was
going on just he's got something with
his feet he can't run full speed they
knew then somebody knew then the helmet
issue was percolating i don't expect
much from hard knocks chris this is not
a reality show it's an infomercial it's
produced by nfl films and i think the
raiders have been given
more say over the content than any team
that has ever agreed to do hard knocks
and i think john gruden is going to
craft whatever is included in the
episode to ensure that it paints antonio
brown and the raiders in the most
favorable possible light yes agreed i
think that they'll probably show that
press conference right there that we
just saw john gruden making those
comments i don't think he's gonna make
any comments directly to hbo i would be
shocked if he addressed it that way i
bet you they play that we hear the
narrator talk about brown not being
there because of these issues and i
would imagine it kind of gets glossed
over just like that within the show
if the arbitrator has any sense of flair
or drama a decision will be issued today
so they can cram the outcome
into tomorrow night's episode of hard
knocks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports